[Music]
[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
our sweet letter secrets preview show
for episode 317 chapter 52 the raid
which used to be called the master but
then they changed and now here we are
now today I'll be bringing you my three
clues about our next episode and gifting
you with a new interview with the lovely
Vanessa Morgan talking about the one
thing we're all dying to see whoo
cryptic tees but first let's take a look
back at your hisses and kisses from our
Sweetwater after show for episode 316
aka the musical episode now first up we
need to talk about the fact that there
was a lot of love for all the songs in
the musical but 17 was by far that y'all
were the one that were freaking out the
most about now kicking us off Carlotta's
kirkin wrote kisses to the fact that 17
my favorite song ever was sang by my two
all-time favorite ships oh that's so
sweet and Lilly H added in all caps
I should mention oMG Cole's voice blends
so well with Lilly's I know right who
knew that Cole Sprouse was hiding such a
sensational voice from us
and keeping it going Charlene Greenhill
posted kisses to all the amazing
seventeen performances I'm living for it
and of course kisses to the finest Chad
Michael Murray Edgar I'm living for that
also
Sharleen girl you're speaking my
language but it seems like Carly Grenier
is not gonna be swayed by Edgar's pretty
face because she said hisses to the
weird slow clapping it made me
uncomfortable and kisses to Betty for
wearing the sweater that she wore at
juggs bday party in season one yes I
loved that Betty wore that sweater again
because first of all it's cute as hell
and secondly I love it when celebs and
TV characters wear the same things twice
because it makes me feel better about
when I'm an outfit repeater which is
like everyday moving on Sophia's Dell as
Dale sorry girl is
the key observations writing kisses to
Archie for not getting punched in this
episode such a good point Sophie good
job Archie and Gwyneth Edwards added
never thought I'd say this but kisses -
Penelope blossom High River Lodge and
Hermione Lodge because even though they
infuriate me constantly at least they
showed up to watch their children
perform yeah Alice Cooper where the hell
were you why is everyone else from the
farm there but you weren't clapping
right next to Edgar ever Nevers fine
form questions next up Julia Gomez was
all about that Cheryl and Tony reunion
Kashima commented kisses to the shown
e-content love that they are together
again same but Brian chick one do is
having some mixed thoughts about Tony's
behavior and wrote but that threesome
thing was uh I don't know how to feel
about it and now I can't erase it from
my head yeah I don't know about you but
I was just like awkwardly giggling
during Tony's bisexual ballad I also
just loved the way that Vanessa Morgan
was like pointing and the fact that the
Riverdale editors added in those extra
whoosh sound effects to the moment look
I love the fact that Tony was determined
to figure out the real reasons behind
Cheryl's weird behavior over these past
episodes and it was great to learn more
blossom backstory but honestly we are
way overdue for answers about Tony's
past and Vanessa Morgan totally agrees
with me take a look at what she said
which character would you like to learn
more about I picked you I would pick me
myself as well of settings you know so
being here Shoni me it's only because I
literally know nothing about my
background yes where I find I know a
little bit of every other characters
background I really don't know mine or
sweet peas or things so between our
little gang I would love to know more
about like what happened to my parents
Drive siblings what was feels like in
your family these are things that we are
all wondering about as well have you
discovered any more about Tony's
background no do you yourself have any
ideas are you pitching anything to
Roberto
I haven't pitched in
thing you know that just reminds me we
have maybe I shakes and they can forgive
us let's add that and episode I just
kind of come up with my own thing like
in my mind my parents are in jail that's
just kind of like how I envisioned it
removing my dad's in jail and my mom
kind of disappeared out of the picture
you know maybe drugs she is from the
south side no item until I stayed with
my uncle hmm yeah that's kind of what
I've been thinking one at least one or
two of the parents are in jail yeah
great minds what is still on your Tony
bucket list for season three besides
seeing her back story of the family I
would love to see her still being the
strong confident independent girl that
she was when you met her in season two
she didn't take BS from anybody and I
want us to make sure she sticks to that
and I'd like to see her not forget about
her boys yeah oh geez yes now what are
your theories about Tony's past start
sharing them with me in the comments and
I'll be getting to them in just a little
bit and while you're doing that
let's also play this week's promo so
that we can get pumped up for all the
drama and danger coming our way in
episode 317 this is Cheryl blossom
mr. ever and ever is a yummy snack
there are people with grudges they want
me dead
I'm dangerous as you sneak me into the
farm bill we're gonna get rid of the
gargoyles choking I'm ready to say
I can tell you it's going to be a
delicious episode so let's snack on my
three clues to help curb your Riverdale
cravings before chapter 52 the raid
number one hermione may be getting death
threats but something smells fishy in
the lodge household number two
Betty's trusty bobby pin makes a
comeback and so does something else that
bug head fans have been waiting to see
and number three all hail Cheryl
honestly Madeleine Pech is just really
great this week that's all I want to say
now while we wait for things to go down
let's chat it up with a round of your
live comments and questions so let's get
store it started um so first off my
producers saying that you guys are
loving my hair and my shirt thank you
I've had this shirt all season I've been
waiting for a good episode to wear it
and I think that this is this is that
episode I just think it's really cute
and it goes is our set really well and
things
thanks guys my hair's blonder let's dig
into the comments though crazy mash says
what if Betty asked for Cheryl's help to
spy on the farm and then Cheryl agrees
and then once she starts going she
decides not to quit ah I'm dying all I
can say is like I said in the clue
Cheryl is such a scene stealer this week
she is prime
Cheryl blossom we get a lot of great
cousin scenes together a lot of fun
references that we've been totally
missing out on a lot of really cool
callbacks to season 1 remember season 1
I really enjoyed tonight's episode
you're gonna like it too um let's see
jasmine fairy says I can't wait to see
Chad Michael Murray and his dreamy eyes
and his dreamy eyes so bad boy side as
well Oh Chad Michael Murray is the
perfect Edgar ever and ever I was not
anticipating that and I was not thinking
that that is what who they were gonna
cast but he's great
he's equal parts eerie and endearing so
I'll leave you with that legend of Mario
says I think Cheryl's gonna get sucked
into the farm in this episode you guys
cheryl is strong she tells people what
to do they don't tell her what to do so
Generosa 95 what if Alice were to have
Betty kidnapped by the farm and tries to
force her into joining I mean Alice Rd
Center and his sisters are quiet mercy
and Betty broke herself out so if she
was gonna do that again then oh yeah
Alice does return this week and she
looks phenomenal but no I don't think
she'll get kidnapped crazy mash I have a
weird feeling that Betty is going to
invade the farm to find a recording of
Alice's confessions and that Betty is
going to run into Alice there or
something like that please confirm this
well I did confirm that we are getting
to see Alice and that she looks great
but that is all I will confirm for now
when it's seriously I'm not being mad if
Shoni breaks up they just got back
together I know it's been a big yo-yo
Shoni ride I'm not gonna comment on
their relationship in this episode you
guys will find out but there's not
really much to tell um let's see Jessica
Rock says yeah episode 17 had been
leaked and I've seen all the scenes with
Cheryl in them it had been leaked what
and she said to Betty I'm not your bait
anymore I'm still gonna be the farm I
don't know how things episodes leaked
this is crazy
you guys are getting enough spoilers
between Roberto and like this show and
all the other things out there don't
leak episodes Caroline are are we gonna
see the core for at all this episode or
at least B and V I love them so much and
love your shirt by the way the core for
once again is kind of split we won't be
seeing them altogether however you will
be seeing different pairings of the core
for that we haven't seen in a while and
yes we're getting B and V it's just a
little bit but needs to be happy
but yes we will be getting I can't
figure out like the math of it but good
combos of the core for okay Sarah wait
what happens to Jughead that was Jughead
falling out of the window yeah honestly
it's Riverdale apparently people just
get in danger every single week so this
week it actually looks terrifying and
I'm really worried for Jughead but yeah
because they haven't jumped out of a
window so far yet this season so why not
let's put that awesome stunt team in use
there is one scene tonight where you
feel like you're watching arrow
so that was kind of cool um Kate is
Betty finally getting her jacket betty
has her Southside jacket do you mean the
pink version that we talked about
earlier this season no but we've seen
her rock her Southside jacket and she
looks like sensational and it was going
to say it's phenomenal again but I just
said Alice looks phenomenal so I'm
trying to spread the adjectives out for
the Cooper women Ruby maybe Tony was
adopted and was abused so her parents
got sent to jail then went to live with
her uncle I don't necessarily like that
theory because I don't want to ever
think about Miz Tony getting abused
however I think that it's good that
we're starting to think of her backstory
maybe it'll spark something because I
would love to know more about Tony I
think she was such a great character she
popped out in season two and I'd love to
know how she became so badass and if you
guys remember in last week's episode
when I ran that video with Bernadette
Beck who plays peaches and cream she
actually knows all of peaches backstory
and that her mom owned a pawn shop that
the Serpent's kept raiding and it she
knows more of her own backstory than
Vanessa Morgan knows of Tony's not cool
mckaela mckaela Taylor welcome back girl
so my drinking game this week should
definitely be every time Cheryl refers
to Betty as cousin shot yeah yeah if
you're over the age of 21 that's a good
place to start for your drinking game or
you could do soda or whatever you like
Bella adventures what's the dynamic of
Gladys's relationship with Betty that is
still to be determined as we've seen
Gladys and Betty have had scenes
together but their interactions have
been very surface level they've never
even had like an intense sit-down
I don't know if Gladys likes buddy I
don't know if that he likes Gladys I
don't think she does because she helped
Jughead destroy her candy drug trailer
but I would love to see those two ladies
hash it out uh here we go Brian is
hoping hoping something Betty does
causes Alice to either a break from the
farms hold or reveal she is deep
undercover in it oh that would be
awesome
can you imagine because since Alice has
that new job as
I forget what it is a news anchor or
something like that can you imagine if
the entire time she was like I'm
actually it's like an undercover exposé
and I'm just really doing this that
would be so great in such a great twist
do I think it'll happen no but that
would be awesome
sawed lover 21 says Sheryl blossom is
going to take charge this episode I can
already tell she doesn't follow rules
she gives them and she's not taking BS a
queen only awesome and there's like one
scene in particular it's so quick
tonight but it's in the bathroom and
she's just it's just so classic season
one Sheryl and it's amazing okay
hello it's me says Vanessa posted a
picture of a wolf tattoo a while ago
what happened to that was it a character
tattoo or a Vanessa Morgan tattoo I
didn't know anything about a wolf
character maybe like it symbolizes that
like Tony's kind of a lone wolf or a
leader of a pack I don't know
Crona Stewart since Veronica's parents
are separating does this mean Hyrum is
going to start coming after Hermione
after what she did to him I mean I think
that Hyrum just kind of like we saw in
the last episode I think that he's the
one that really just wants the divorce
so we're really seeing Veronica try and
figure out what that means for her
family dynamic going forward I feel
really badly for Veronica because it's a
really tough spot for her to be in
clearly her parents don't always get
along but seeing the split up of any
marriage is hard for a kid to go through
I was thinking how weird would it be a
Hyrum and GLaDOS got together because I
don't want SP with GLaDOS anymore I
never really wanted it to happen but
they're happening right now in this
palace so much taylor tony is getting
targeted by a new gang y'all the
werewolves if there's another gang
coming to Riverdale I'm going to lose it
can you imagine and if that actually
ends up happening I know how many gangs
are in this town it's supposed to be a
really small town and yet there's like a
thousand different gangs and and they
all just like heat and multiplying
you'll see tonight like I'm like weird
all these people come from specific itty
bitty town this massive and like there's
all these drugs like what is going on
Dallas fans be cray guys I'm here with
you Oh sad times sad times
Johanna J will we get more romantic
bug-head scenes besides the pillow talk
one pillow talk one mmm but in terms of
bug-head scenes your guess is as good as
mine
I adore them some people like to rep
sports teams I personally like to rep my
favourite ships so March Madness this is
how I rep March Madness Abigail
I love phallus as a part of it but I'm
sad is another way and I cannot lose
bug-head
oh her emotions are taking over I'm not
sure what she's saying but yes we will
not lose bug-head if we do that everyone
will explode VT who's gonna get custody
of Ronnie Hyrum or Hermione I mean they
both suck this is true at this point I
even forgot that like getting custody of
a kid is even a thing because the
Riverdale teens already act like they
run the town anyways Veronica does
another thing tonight where I'm like
aren't you supposed to be like 16 how
are you doing this she already like owns
and operates her own like alcohol-fueled
speakeasy so I'm pretty sure she can
take care of herself but I don't know
maybe she'll emancipate herself that's
that's a thing that happens on TV but
not really much in real life so there
you go okay we're gonna start winding it
down let's see guys are sending so many
good ones which one have we not done
okay
Sojin I says Jughead almost dies again
can't he just catch a break from almost
death I know right it seems like it's
the other Jughead is on the brink of
death or Archie's on the brink of death
at least Archie I feel like he's really
not toughened up this year but he's
really proven himself because at the
beginning of season 3 when Jughead and
Archie went on their little road trip
and jugheads like you're kind of a
liability because you always get in
trouble it's nice to see that Archie is
no longer just kind of like what's going
on
he's gotten the crap kicked out of
himself quite a bit this season but it's
toughened up alright just a couple more
Arielle says Shoni is having that bug
head roller coaster what happens when
another argument goes on and is there
another riot right yeah I feel like bug
head in season two had their whole
up-and-down this year at Shoney's time
to go through it all it is what it
happens to be okay
lastly Jessica says I love how Cheryl
said shut up Tony instead of saying shut
up Heather I just loved the musical
episode I did too I think you guys are
gonna really love tonight's episode
though and we are going to end it there
now thank you all so much for tuning in
to this week's live Sweetwater preview
for episode 317 chapter 52 the raid and
be sure to check back with me for our
after-show because I'm gonna be breaking
down the most shocking moment and you
definitely don't want to miss it
but for now please give this video a
like and then hit subscribe and then
head on down to the comments to see if
you can crack my three clues and which
questions about Tony topaz's past are
you dying to see answered tell me tell
me and I'll talk to you soon river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]